ومعنا الان من اوديسا نتاليا المتحدثه
باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب في الجيش
الاوكراني اهلا بك السيده هوني واريد ان
اسالك عن الوضع في اوديسا حاليا كيف يمكن
وصفه وتاثير الضربات الروسيه حتى الان
ظروف
العدو طوال ثلاثه ليالي كان يقصف البنيه
التحتيه للموانئ كل ميناء قد
انضم لاعمال نقل الحبوب قد تعرض للضرر
وتدمرت البنيه التحتيه في تلك
الموانئ وحاولوا ان يدمروا كل ما يمكن ان
يساعد اوكرانيا في
الاستمرار باتفاقيه الحبوب للاسف هذه
الهجمات كانت قد ادى لسقوط ضحايا في
اوديسا وضواحيها ايضا هاجم العدو نيكلايف
بصواريخ من نوع اسكندر
ودمر منازل المتعدده الطوابق حيث كان حيث
سقطت ارواح من المدنيين وجرح البعض خمس
اطفال جرحوا الدوله الارهابيه روسيا
حتى تنشر الرعب في اوكرانيا تستخدم وسائل
مختلفه وصواريخ مختلفه في نفس الوقت
تستخدم ما يزيد عن 20 صاروخ ومسيره ضد
القطاع الجنوبي اليوم في الليل من جديد
قصفوا الجنوب ولكن ليس الموانئ بل المناطق
حيث يقوم
الفلاحين بجمع
المحصود
وجرح عفوا حرقت بعض
المستودعات ودمرت المعدات وجرح البعض من
المزارعين نعم هذا القصف المتصاعد من
الجانب روسيا والاهداف التي تستهدفها هل
الهدف فعلا هو منع تصدير الحبوب ام هناك
هدف عسكري اوسع برايك
لا تبحث هنا عن اهداف عسكريه كل ما يريدوه
هو ان يقوم المجتمع الدولي
باخفاض العقوبات وتقليل العقوبات والضم
البنك الروسي لنظام السويفت واعلنوا انهم
يريدوا ان يتاجروا بحبوبهم وان يبيعوا
حبوبهم للدول الذين يختاروهم ولكن الحبوب
اصلا اوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا لك نتاليا
المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب في
الجيش الاو